the president of China arrived in Moscow
this morning in an apparent show of
support for Russian President Vladimir
Putin in the Ukraine war this comes just
days after an arrest warrant was issued
by for Putin rather by the international
criminal court over the weekend Putin
made an unannounced visit to a city that
Russia seized from Ukraine last year
after a brutal battle Raymond ascencio
is in Ukraine Ramey good morning
good morning Vlad That's Right XI
jinping's arrival to Moscow is a strong
show of solidarity for Vladimir Putin
and this is something that the Kremlin
will no doubt exploit but it's also the
Optics of she shaking hands with Putin
just days ago the Russian leader was
accused of war crimes
in a surprise visit President Putin
drove himself through russian-occupied
Mario pulse Saturday inspecting newly
built facilities in what's believed to
be his closest tour to the front lines
of this war he started
Russia's military bombed seized then
annexed the Ukrainian Port City last May
damaging or destroying nearly all of its
buildings
Putin is a criminal returning to the
scene of the crime said Mario Paul's
exiled mayor the international criminal
court agrees it issued a warrant for
Putin's arrest for the deportation and
Abduction of children from Ukraine to
Russia those accusations did little to
dissuade today's visit by China's
president
Xi Jinping saying his trip to Moscow is
a journey of friendship cooperation and
peace
across Ukraine there has been no peace
for over a year where daily shelling can
mean random death waiting at a bus stop
like in the front line city of Harrison
While daily prayers go unanswered how do
you find peace in this time of War
this church is like a hospital for my
soul we come here to pray together and
find comfort
and president xi's visit is expected to
run through Wednesday after that he's
expected to speak with Ukrainian
President Vladimir zielinski zielinski
has told Beijing to not supply any
weapons whatsoever to Russia Vlad
all right raminosancio and Ukraine Ramey
thank you